elon has a perspective on the world
that's similar to bitcoin folks
which i really like which is like
thinking long
term it's how visionaries think it's
like how will
if i take these ideas what
and the ideas hold true
what will the world look like in 20 30
50 years
and think about everything in that way
yeah i like
bezos view which is uh is essentially
how do you minimize regret how do you
accelerate your life mentally and go to
80 90 100 150 years whatever we end up
being you know fortunate enough to live
to and then look backwards
yes and say this decision that i'm going
to make i have two
options which one is going to be the one
that i least regret
and if you continue to make decisions
that way
one you have that long-term view kind of
built-in because you're working
backwards
uh two you are ultimately going to
optimize for
uh minimal regret but also three is
even if you only look forward ten years
that's much much further than most
people do
and so it gives you a significant
advantage and i think that um bitcoin
has kind of this like um
you know proxy for time as we talked
about uh
interplant uh planetary travel where
there's multiple steps from creating a
reusable rocket to landing it to
you know all the stuff all the way to
simple things just like
if you're simply trying to figure out
where the world's going to be 30 years
from now
you know bill gates says that we
overestimate what we can do in one year
underestimate what we can do in 10.
well to me it's a um kind of degree of
uh mistake if you will 10 years maybe
you're off by 10
well if that line of progress continues
20 years you may be off by
100 and thirty years you may be off by a
thousand percent
right but like almost the further you go
out the more inaccurate you become
and so i think that people who
want to iterate their way to success
right that's a common thing in like the
startup world
end up actually following
kind of the breadcrumbs to where the
world is taking them
but people like an elon musk a jeff
bezos
a jack dorsey all the way down the line
all these innovators
they actually say to themselves there is
a point in time in the future
where there's a world i want to
construct and then they go and they
construct it
regardless of the short-term iterations
and incentives
it is just they're driving towards that
point and i think that it's this whole
idea of having this like
you know kind of set vision and this uh
refusal to kind of move or budge off of
that
it's what makes them special
you